you can now watch the sentencing of a 17
year old that is Marcus Walker the 17
year old pleading guilty to the murder
of 14 year old Jermaine calls this is
after he stabbed him to death including
back in 2021 just to warn you that what
you're about to hear could contain some
distressing content but let's go live to
the Old Bailey now
seated until I tell you to stand up
you're here today to be sentenced for
the murder of Jermaine cools on the 18th
of November 2021 for possession of the
murder weapon and for an offense of
causing Grievous bodily harm with intent
contrary to section 18 of the offenses
against the person act committed on the
1st of July
2022 whilst you were in custody awaiting
trial for Jermaine's murder and then to
refer to the latter offense as the
section 18 offense
you pleaded guilty to possession of the
knife used in the murder on the 18th of
March of 2022
you initially pleaded not guilty to the
murder but changed your plea to guilty
on the 9th of January of this year
you pleaded guilty to the section 18
offense on the 10th of March 2023
following the addition of a second count
to the indictment which had originally
charged you with murder
uh well that hearing is continuing at
the old bayley today and the teenager
being sentenced who murdered the 14 year
old Jermaine calls in Croydon back in
November
2021 it was a brutal Street attack a
machete involved he is currently being
sentenced in what is a landmark
televised hearing that you can see
unfold here on skyne's first juvenile to
be sentenced
um and those judges remarks and
sentencing brought to you on live
television it's all part of the media's
attempt to go inside the courtroom to
understand the sentences that are passed
and the reasons behind them but the
juvenile in question Marcus Walker is
just 17 and he stabbed Jermaine calls
seven times in an attack that was
described as being of extreme ferocity
it happened during a fight near to West
Croydon station in November 2021 I
believe we can now rejoin proceedings at
the Old Bailey let's listen in
Walker you are here today to be
sentenced for the murder of Jermaine
cools on the 18th of November 2021
the possession of the murder weapon and
for an offensive causing Grievous bodily
harm with intent contrary to section 18
of the offenses against the person act
on committed on the 1st of July 2022
whilst you were in custody awaiting
trial for Jermaine's murder
I'm going to refer to that offense as
the section 18 offense
you pleaded guilty to possession of the
knife used in the murder on the 18th of
March of 2022
you initially pleaded not guilty to the
murder but changed your plea to guilty
on the 9th of January of this year
you pleaded guilty to the section 18
offense on the 10th of March this year
following the addition of a second count
to the indictment which had originally
charged you with an attempted murder
the statutory surcharge applies to this
case
this is yet another case involving the
senseless murder of a young teenager
committed for reasons that no mature
adult can fathom
Jermaine cools was only 14 when you
killed him
he was the youngest victim of fatal
knife crime in London in 2021
tragically since that date and to this
day
there have been many further murders of
young teenagers since Jermaine's death
and nothing seems to deter the likes of
you from going onto the Streets of
London and elsewhere armed with lethal
weapons easily acquired on the internet
intent upon serious violence with no
thought for the consequences for the
victims their innocent loved ones nor
for the consequences for themselves
in the words of your own counsel this
was quotes an appalling Act of Senseless
violence close quotes
the impact of germain's violent and
needless death is immeasurable
his parents have each set out as best
they can
the devastating effects upon them of the
loss of their youngest son
his father says quote he was everything
to us
Sunshine a bright light in this world
a humble child with a lot of Dreams
now we are nothing
just wanting to die to be with Jermaine
close quotes
he describes how they have put a large
picture on Jermaine's bed so that they
can pretend that he is still there
Jermaine's mother describes how since
her beloved son's death
they have quote ceased living and just
existed
their home used to be filled with love
laughter and happiness
it's now a sad and empty house
memories are all they have left
Jermaine will never be forgotten he was
their perfect son
Jermaine was his mother's soulmate she
has not been able to work since his
death
she is an empty shell
she also describes a significant impact
on Jermaine's older brother
both his parents have been diagnosed
with post-traumatic stress disorder
depression and anxiety due to their loss
they are both taking medication and
receiving counseling
there is no sentence which I can pass
which can relieve the pain and loss
which you caused
nothing can bring Jermaine back
no term of years can even begin to
compensate for his family's loss
my job today is to pass a sentence on
you which reflects your culpability for
what you have done
and to pass the appropriate punishment
upon you based upon all the
circumstances of this tragic case
the murder and its surrounding
circumstances were captured on CCTV and
other footage
so these
on the early evening of Thursday the
18th of November 2021 you were out in a
busy street in London Road in Croydon
with your friends you had a large
machete hidden under your clothing
another of your friends Stanley Lopez
was also armed with a large knife
he was disguised with a balaclava your
group were clearly geared up and ready
for serious violence
fourteen-year-old Jermaine was with his
two much older brothers
twenty to seven that evening your group
approached Jermaine's group
there was a tussle between your friend
Stanley Lopez who had drawn a knife
and Jermaine's older brother deloney
during which Jermaine did no more than
to throw a punch
his brother disarmed Lopez of his knife
before he was able to use it and he put
that knife out of Harm's Way
that night was recovered by police and
I've seen a photograph of it
Jermaine would have had absolutely no
idea dear that you and your friends were
armed with lethal weapons and nor that
you were out on that street with the
intention of using them
during the tussle Jermaine stumbled to
the floor
and having briefly got to his feet
possibly because he was pushed by one of
your group he fell again
from that moment he was trapped on the
ground utterly defensive
defenseless and you chose him as your
target
you drew your knife ran towards Jermaine
and stabbed him mercilessly no less than
seven times in his chest abdomen and
shoulder as he tried hopelessly to avoid
the blows
by rolling around on the pavement
he didn't stand a chance
he must have been terrified and in agony
you intended to kill Jermaine and you
achieved your desire
having done so you ran off
public spirited members of the public
helped Jermaine and drove him to the
hospital
efforts to save his life were fruitless
due to the catastrophic loss of blood he
had suffered from the wounds which she
had inflicted two of those wounds were
independently capable of killing him
he was pronounced dead at 1950 that
evening
as you fled the scene you discarded your
knife which has never been found
you lay low for two and a half hours
before taking a taxi to your home in
Bromley
you arrived home at about 20 past 10
your mother was there
in the early hours of the following
morning you left your home on the
pretext of going to get food
you didn't do that instead you went and
got a taxi
and got away from the area
once you realized you'd gone your mother
checked a tablet which you'd taken from
her and that showed that you'd been
involved in the stabbing and engaged in
online chats with your like-minded
friends who were advising you to get rid
of your phone and your clothing to avoid
being caught
you took a taxi to Thornton Heath
arriving at quarter past one the
following morning you stayed at the
night at a care home in which a female
acquaintance of yours lived
you were last seen before your arrest
the following afternoon when you left
that accommodation with two females
in the footage from that address you
made sure that your identity was
concealed from the CCTV cameras
you were not seen again until six weeks
later when on the 28th of December 2021
police attended an address in Upper
Norwood to arrest the occupant and quite
by chance they found you there
you were spoken to by police you gave a
false name but eventually admitted who
you were and were arrested for
Jermaine's murder
you did not answer police questions in
interview
you were reminded to felt some young
offender Institution
on the 4th of April 2022 an officer
found drill lyrics in your cell in which
you celebrated the murder of Jermaine
the second serious offense of violence
for which I have to deal with you took
place on the 1st of July 2022 when you
were still on remand for the murder at
hmp Felton
you and four other inmates were in the
exercise route yard at about 10 30.
there is poor quality footage of the
incident
however several prison officers were
able to describe what took place
awesome
well we're following proceedings at the
old bayley for legal reasons we have to
take breaks there in the judges
sentencing remarks but just to remind
you what we're watching
um is a landmark case in terms of the
fact that a juvenile is being sentenced
and you can watch that sentencing on TV
today it's the sentencing of 17 year old
Marcus Walker he pleaded guilty to the
murder of 14 year old Jermaine calls so
he stabbed him to death in Croydon in
2021 we can now head back to the Old Bay
you put man's to sleep close quotes
when you were estranged you were
shouting quote that's what snitches get
close quotes
to one of your group banishan
balakrishnan who like you was also on
remand for murder you said quotes I had
to start it that's what you get
to which Mr balakrishnan replied rest in
peace
the two of you were seen to be laughing
you added quotes that's what happens to
snitches that's how we wipe them out
close quotes
you were crowing that you had quotes
smoked him and as you were locked in
your cell you made gun signs
when your cell was searched and
improvised weapon
memories your group left him unconscious
he had lost control of his bowels and
bladder and vomited while still
unconscious
when he briefly regained Consciousness
he begged the officers to save his life
saying quotes I have a daughter
he then fell back into unconsciousness
he was taken to hospital by air
ambulance he had suffered increased
pressure and a bleed to his brain which
was life-threatening and has been life
changing
he underwent lengthy surgery but is left
with permanent and significant brain
damage
his cognitive functions are badly
affected he will require lengthy
Rehabilitation and ongoing long-term
input from multi-disciplinary teams to
support him in reaching his full
potential
again following your arrest you answered
no comment in interview
this is a complex sentencing exercise
you were 16 when you committed the
murder you are now 17.
the sentence for murder is fixed by law
in the light of your age the sentence is
one of detention for life at his
Majesty's pleasure
I have to set the minimum term which you
must serve before you are eligible to be
considered full release by the parole
board
that minimum term must reflect the
seriousness of the murder offense and
any offense associated with it it must
also reflect the section 18 offense
by schedule 21 of the sentencing act
2020 as amended at paragraph 5A brackets
two the starting point where a knife was
taken to the scene of the murder in
circumstances where I am satisfied you
took the knife to the scene and you
intended to and did use it in committing
the murder the starting point is 17
years
that starting point applies to those
aged 15 or 16 at the date of the offense
you were 16 years and two months
the starting point in your case is
therefore 17 years however I note that
had you been 10 months older the
starting point would have gone up to 23
years
the fact that you were in possession of
a machete on the night of the murder is
already taken into account in that
starting point as is the fact as I have
found that you had an intention to kill
Jermaine
there are significant aggravating
factors
the first is your previous conviction
for possession of a large rambo-style
weapon on school premises on the 27th of
January of 2020
you pleaded guilty to that offense and
received a nine-month referral order
secondly on the 12th of April 2021 in
the context of county lines drug dealing
you were found by police to have a
hunting knife
you were not prosecuted for that offense
as you were found to have been the
victim of modern slavery
third on the 6th of October 2021 when on
bail for the April matter and only six
weeks before you murdered Jermaine you
were found in possession of yet another
lethal knife this time one with a 50
centimeter blade
you told officers that you always
carried knives as without one you felt
that you were walking to your death
you were again bailed
that offense was withdrawn following
your guilty plea to Jermaine's murder
I have seen photographs of all those
horrific knives which are sadly typical
of those which these courts see on an
almost daily basis
there is absolutely no legitimate reason
for carrying those weapons and your
possession of them significantly
aggravates the seriousness of the
offense
four you were on bail for two offenses
of possession of knives and in breach of
a bail condition not to enter Croydon
five the murder involved a sustained
attack on a defenseless 14 year old
child with a deadly weapon in the
context of gang violence
in close proximity to members of the
public
six you were under the influence of
cannabis upon which I note you were
dependent
seven you sought to evade capture and
were successful in doing so for some six
weeks
and finally the drill lyrics written by
you and found in April 2022 do in my
view demonstrate a lack of remorse on
your part at least at that date
I emphasize that a lack of remorse in
itself is not an aggravating Factor
the mitigation comes from the very
helpful report which I have read upon
you
those can be found at sections T three
to seven of the digital case system
the principal mitigation is your youth
or yo of course your age is already
reflected in the reduced minimum term
on the 7th of February of 2022 a
conclusive Brown's decision was made
that you were the victim of modern
slavery
you ran away from home at a young age
and were recruited into the world of
street gangs and exploited
first you became embroiled in dealing
drugs in a county lines Enterprise
it is an all too familiar picture at
this court
that provides background and some
explanation but no excuse whatsoever for
you to engage in the sort of violence
which you have chosen
you presented to the doctors with the
symptoms of complex post-traumatic
stress disorder following your childhood
experiences which included the murder of
your father cousin and Friends
you also have some traits of conduct the
social disorder
however there is no significant
impairment in your cognitive functioning
you are quotes a complex and vulnerable
young man who has experienced a great
deal of trauma and abuse in your young
life
you have recently shown some regret for
what you have done
it was always accepted on your behalf
that you were the person responsible for
the unlawful killing of Jermaine it was
however necessary for you to be assessed
by mental health professionals in order
to determine whether the partial defense
of diminished responsibility was
available to you
once it became clear that it was not you
will rightly advised that you had no
alternative but to plead guilty to
murder and you did so on the 9th of
January 2023 the day when your trial had
been due to start
in all the circumstances a reduction
from the minimum term for the murder of
just under 1 6 is in my view merited
your possession of the murder weapon is
already reflected in the minimum term
starting point
for an adult for such an offense the
relevant guideline gives a starting
point of 18 months custody
due to your youth I reduced that term by
one-third to 12 months and then further
to eight months to reflect your early
guilty plea
the group attack upon a fellow inmate in
which you played a leading role and
which involves significant planning was
an extremely serious offense
it was a Revenge attack Upon Our Youth
who you perceive to be a snitch
the victim suffered particularly grave
and life-threatening injury
that offense fell within category 1A of
the relevant guideline with a starting
point of for an adult of 12 years and a
range of 10 to 16 years
there are a number of aggravating
factors
one the fact that this was an attack
within a custodial setting
to the fact that you were on remand
having at that stage pleaded not guilty
to Jermaine's murder and three your
previous offending and criminality
the mitigating factors are those which I
have set out above in relation to the
murder I do not repeat them
I note that you had been the victim of
violence while in custody having been
stabbed in the head from which you bear
a noticeable scar
in relation to this offense the
mitigating factors balance out the
aggravating factors
I emphasize that I have guarded against
any double counting and born firmly in
mind the youth guideline and the
guidelink guideline relating to mentally
disordered offenders as well as totality
you were 16 and three quarters at the
date of the section 18 offense
applying the youth guideline a notional
determinate term is one of eight years
namely two-thirds of the 12-year adult
term
you were originally charged with
attempted murder to which you pleaded
not guilty
you entered a plea to the section 18
offense on the 10th of March 2023 your
trial had been listed for July
in my view you deserve 25 credit for
plea which gives a term of six years
I then have to consider the
dangerousness provisions
in your case I am of the firm view that
despite your Youth and the other matters
to which I have referred
on all the facts you do present a
significant risk of serious harm to the
public occasioned by the commission by
you or further specified offenses
the author of the pre-sentence report is
of the same view and assesses your risk
as very high
in my judgment acknowledging that a life
sentence is a last resort the section 18
offense is in itself serious enough to
justify a life sentence and there is no
reliable estimate of the length of time
you will remain a danger
in any event of course you will be
serving the life sentence which I will
impose for the murder of Jermaine
the minimum term which I attach to the
life sentence for the murder
must include a term to reflect the
section 18 offense as the sentence which
I impose for that offense will run
concurrently with the sentence on the
murder
having started at 17 years for the
appropriate minimum term I have
concluded that the aggravating factors
for the murder outweigh the mitigation
and that a minimum term of 19 years
would have been appropriate in your case
before considering the section 18
offense
from that minimum term should be
deducted three years just under 1 6 to
reflect your plea of guilty which gives
16 years
having determined that the notional
determinant sentence for the section 18
would have been six years I Am pro I
propose to increase the minimum term for
the murder to one of 19 years to reflect
totality
you stand up please
the sentences I pass upon you are as
follows for the murder detention at his
Majesty's pleasure
the minimum term before you will be
considered for release by the parole
board will be one of 19 years
for the possession of the murder weapon
there will be a sentence of eight months
detention to run concurrently
for the causing previous bodily harm
with intent there will be a
discretionary life sentence of detention
at his Majesty's pleasure with a minimum
term of four years that sentence will
run concurrently to the sentence for the
murder
you have spent 497 days in detention on
remand which will count towards your
sentence so the minimum term is 19 years
less 497 days
if the information which I have been
provided with as to the days in
detentional remand proves to be
inaccurate then the prosecution or
defense must notify the court so that
the case can be re-listed to correct the
calculation as soon as possible and in
any event within 56 days of today
you will not be released when you have
served that minimum term indeed you will
only ever be released if the parole
board consider that you no longer pose a
risk of harm to the public
the sentence
foreign
that sentencing at the old Balia minimum
term
of 19 years before Marcus Walker the 17
year old you see here on your screen
will be considered for parole
um Marcus Walker has been jailed for
life for the murder of a 14 year old
Jermaine cause as I said a minimum term
as you just heard there from the judge
of 19 years Walker pleaded guilty to
Jermaine Cole's murder after he stabbed
him to death in Croydon in 2021 the Met
police have since released footage of
the attack
and a warning that some viewers may find
what we are about to bring you
distressing
TV footage of that night in November
2021 Marcus Walker highlighted in blue
Lungi with a knife in the moments just
before the stabbing
Jermaine calls then seen walking away he
was later driven to Croydon hospital by
a member of the public
but he died later that evening
and then in this footage you can see
Marcus Walker leaving the scene still
carrying a knife
also's Becky Cottrell is at the Old
Bailey Forest this afternoon after the
judge handed down that life sentence a
minimum term of 19 years before Marcus
Walker is considered for parole
um Becky interesting to hear that the
judge's remarks and the reasoning behind
her decision
we actually mentioned the lack of
remorse that he had shown and the threat
that he posed to the public we heard
some really horrific details today in
court and saw all horrific CCTV
um footage Jermaine calls was just 14
years old when he was stabbed by Marcus
Walker now 17 then 16 and despite the
fact that he is under 18 the judge
lifted the legal restrictions on naming
him Anon and broadcasting that
sentencing deeming it in the public
interest and we were taken through that
CCTV footage today by the prosecution
showing what was described as a tussle
between the two groups and we saw in
slow time as well the moment when Marcus
Walker pulls the machete out of his
jacket and runs towards Germaine cools
on the floor and it was it was really
disturbing to see that he kept
establishing the main cause as he was
rolling around and I think as well when
you see Jermaine cools get up and and
walked off helped by two members of
public you perhaps wouldn't realize just
how badly injured he had been but he had
been stabbed at least seven times and
despite being taken to hospital he died
because he'd simply lost too much blood
now Jermaine calls family were in court
today they were visibly emotional as you
would expect and two very powerful
Victim Impact statements were read out
on behalf of his mother and father just
some bits that really struck me from
that his mother Lorraine Dudek said that
since Jermaine had been killed she'd
been able to work suffering PTSD
depression and anxiety she described
Jermaine as her soul mate and said that
now she feared living into old age
having to endure this constant pain
Julius calls Jermaine's father said he
hoped that one day God could return all
the pain of what they are suffering now
on Marcus Walker it was also interesting
to hear that a prison officer had
discovered while Marcus Walker was on
remand some rap lyrics
that basically admitted to the murder of
Jermaine cools and we heard some of
those lyrics read out today and they
even had to be translated they were
drill rap lyrics and include the
prosecution felt that we wouldn't be
able to understand them but basically
they spoke about stabbing Jermaine cools
and saying even though he wasn't a
member of a gang Marcus Walker was still
glad that he had stabbed him now defense
made the case
that Marx Walker was a member of a
county Lions gang and had been
criminally exploited they also said that
he was a victim of modern slavery but
the judge was very clear that was no
excuse whatsoever for his behavior